hi i'm kristen bell and i'm kirby hal
baptist and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
yeah i've googled myself before but like
i don't have a google alert on myself so
i don't think that's healthy i haven't
[Music]
really scare me why is kristen bell
so annoying so loud so talkative no why
is there somebody why does she have a
child's voice the voice of gossip girl
all you don't know why i am you're the
voice of xoxo gossip girl the original
yeah whoa this woman has wow
i am the voice of gossip girl when
veronica mars was canceled don ostroff
was running the cw at the time they had
green lit a show called gossip girl i
was five years too old to play a
character i called dawn and i said um
i'm out of work but there's a narrator
and i love doing voice-over work can i
be the narrator and then she called the
creators and she was like yeah you could
totally do that and it's just sort of
you know it's this salacious voice of
all social media and you're terrified
that that she'll highlight you oh man
xoxo
okay why does kristen bell
wear gloves in the pool
yeah
that's a valid question
do you wear gloves in the pool yes
let me how does someone know that
because i've talked about it i think
probably someone said tell us something
weird about you that we don't know
okay so here's the thing when my circles
touch your circles
in the pool if they're at all soggy
i have
i have that where it's just like you
really feel like your spine is shooting
backwards out of your body and and also
i have like a little bit of a gag reflex
which proved to be difficult when my
children were learning to swim right you
gotta grab them gotta grab you gotta
grab that two-year-old
if they're doggy paddling so like i
don't like my fingers to touch anything
in the pool and you could touch me
anywhere like if we were in the pool you
could do that no problem yeah but if you
touch your circles to my to my circles i
can barely do it when they're dry even
so if you're in the pool by yourself do
you also wear gloves
um no i i keep my hands up like this
wow i know that sounds like a sincerely
honest scene and i i keep him up like
that everybody laughs and you know i
don't care i'm doing me
your judgments are not my problems why
does kristen bell
i'm an umbrella heart is oh my god the
umbrella harness is actually genius you
need to go on shark tank with that thank
you yeah that is genius i mean i
witnessed this on on the good place so
i'm a good place yeah we shot outside a
lot a lot and it was very very hot we
were just like scorched all the time but
we because we were in makeup and more
importantly hair we couldn't wear the
hats like all the crew had these big
hats to protect you from the sun and we
were just getting like blasted and
sunburned all the time so i thought well
i want to carry around an umbrella but
i'll i will leave it in the shot without
i 100 i'll leave it in the shot i also
like will lose it all day so i thought
what if we can create a backpack so we
sewed it into this it's like a backpack
harness and it shoots out your back and
then all i got to do is go and it goes
really good
you don't know yeah there's a photo of
kristen learning her lines and with the
umbrella and you're in a suit that day
and you literally look like you're
running for president
vote for me dorky president for
president
kirby hall baptist taste
accent accent this is it accent accent
this is my accent and
but i do others
um i was an
australian
on the good place i
am american in queen pins and i played
myself in i was british and veronica
mars i think i have quite a good ear and
i like mimicry and i would love to do
loads of access i'd love to have a role
where i had to do like in like um
tatiana maslany and orphan black you
know when you like do a bunch of
different i think that would be such a
fun thing because i love changing my
hair i love changing makeup i love
changing accents i would love to do
something like that where i was like
characters i would be i would be
show multiple
watching it for sure kirby howl baptiste
wrist piercing
yeah i used to have two wrist piercings
uh they're called dermals this one
rejected this is in the process of
rejection right now which means it's
halfway out of my arm and i will have to
ice it and yank it out the rest of the
way or seek medical attention but who's
got time to go to the er
why did i get these piercings i had a
dream about it i had a dream that i had
piercings in my arm and i woke up the
next day and went and got them okay how
many piercings my septum one i think
five on this ear
four on this ear so that's
ten
eleven
that's it
twelve
16 16 12
17 17
4 in my bar no i think i think it's like
10 or 11.
kirby hal baptiste filmography
imdb baby go on imdb you can see my
whole filmography but also you can see
me in the upcoming movie queen pins
and your imdb is a dream if i could say
something like it looks like it was
curated i got a lot of nonsense on my
page but a lot of regrets kirby how
about tease comedy bang bang oh okay so
comedy bang bang was i think the first
not commercial thing that i did like non
non-commercial um obviously it's
commercial was a tv show and um comedy
bang bang was super super fun um
i did it with a bunch of people from ucb
a lot of people from ucb the upright
citizens brigade which is an improv
school and theater
a lot of the writers and creators of
comedy bang bang were former ucb
students and performers and so a lot of
us kind of got our first
our start basically on comedy bangla and
i did comedy banger i think was my first
official co-star i was so nervous all i
had to do was pretend to be in a cafe
and watch someone see a laptop and i was
so so nervous like no one
can explain to you how nerve-wracking it
is
getting your first role but also being a
co-star or a guest star because you come
into this world that feels so
established and you're the new one like
it's terrifying to which i will say as
actors kristen is very good about this
if you are you know a series regular
you're someone on a show
you've got to remember how it felt to be
really new and how scary that is and how
excited people are and so even if you've
been doing a show for 13 years and
you're like whatever i don't care
for someone who's coming in and they're
like this is the first role i've ever
gotten out of college it's so exciting
and actually it's quite nice to be
reminded of how exciting that is
i love that comedy bang bang bang
who is kristen bells
friend
do we use bests anymore as adults
because there's phases in your life if
it's the person i see the most that's
like my closest girlfriend it's monica
padme but i would say kirby is one of my
best friends but just sometimes you're
in london a lot was kristin bells oh
what is that going to be
who is christian bell on broadway a
variety of roles um
[Music]
becky thatcher and the very short-lived
adventures of tom sawyer
susannah walcott in the crucible
everything else was off-broadway or
regional so too
i've got a lot of
dream shows i'd like to participate in i
mean i really i've done a little night
music twice once at the kennedy center
in dc when we did sondheim and rep there
for a summer and then once out here at
the la opera house and both times i
played frederica who is
13 years old and i really like to play
anne
but i don't read very old on stage well
now i would because of the lights and
the crow's feet and whatnot but um i i
would like to play anne and i would also
really like i want my last thing in my
career and i want to ask like adina to
do this with me i really want to have a
musical written uh of whatever happened
to baby jane and then just have us play
the gals when we're like 80 and then
just be like out i'm done with public
life okay
who does kristen bell
play on central park
well currently well at first i started
playing molly which is a biracial
character and in learning a huge lesson
because the reality is so convoluted but
it was a group of friends that put the
show together and half are black and
half are white we were like let's play a
family but i happen to be the only
person that was playing outside of my
race
and in learning the last couple years
how inappropriate that is not just for
the reasons of a little girl googling
that character who looks like molly
should see someone that looks like molly
but also a biracial actor should have
the opportunity to voice that role
i was replaced by the spectacular emmy
raver lampum and now i play a character
that is the sister of paige the mom who
comes into town and she will be a
character on the third season
and it is racially appropriate for what
i can accomplish
all right who does oh gosh
all right here we go who is
monica padman to kristen bell she's a
business partner and a very close friend
who i love working with and uh we switch
roles with each other a lot
are these real these are the real things
that people have googled mm-hmm okay all
right cool that one's done okay okay who
is kirby how about the question answer
that
that's so funny that's someone who's
like
who the hell is this person who the hell
is kirby about tease um me i'm kevin
baptiste i'm an actress
i'm originally from london i play a lot
of american roles as i do in our new
movie queen pins
paul baptiste
doctor who not really a question
just is that a request for me to be on
the show have i ever been on the show i
have not
have i watched the show
somewhat that's not i've heard the show
is actually great i just you know okay
there's a lot of i'm gonna throw this
out there because alternate perspective
they all deserve to be heard you know
when you're fast typing and you sort of
only half type the sentence did they
mean who is your doctor
uh and to that i would i would actually
also say i don't know who is my doctor
if you know you tell me
gps are not i don't have a gp i don't
have a steady gp
does
kristen bell
go to college uh not currently i did and
i did not graduate same yeah
how long did you go to college for three
years oh okay i did two semesters yeah
does kristen bell
own taco bell uh
okay i don't think we can release that
info yet no no i don't have anything to
do with taco bell
neither do i but i would like to
okay
does kristen bell
have perfect pitch no no no no no no i
have decent pitch pretty good pitch not
perfect pitch
that's that
is kirby hal baptiste
australian
no unfortunately what are you british
british i always say i'm just from
london though because it feels like it's
like almost a different identity is
kirby married
no are you asking
is kirby how about you related to john
baptiste maybe i don't know who john
baptiste is but it's very very possible
although also i think baptiste is quite
a common surname particularly in
caribbean islands
there's a lot of baptists in haiti that
my family aren't haitian so i think it
is though it kind of sounds i think it's
i think baptiste as i understand is
almost like being a smith or something
so i don't think i'm related to all of
them
thanks so much wyoming we will see you
for the next one